[Music]
so
the italian american mob in philadelphia
was philadelphia base but it had
tentacles into
southern new jersey as far east as the
atlantic city
in the late 70s where legalized gambling
came to atlantic city
this was like a treasure trove for the
mob
atlantic city went from a ghetto to a
very powerful
union city the bartenders union the
waitress union
the linen union
[Applause]
[Music]
the philadelphia mob was garfo wanted to
own those unions
because then you could go to the casino
presidents
tell them we're going to have a strike
unless you kick up to us
x amount of dollars annually
it was big money
john mccullough was a union leader
mccullough took control of the unions in
atlantic city
and he wouldn't go along with any of the
mob's plans
of working with them
john mccullough made the mistake of
getting his eyes in
atlantic city all i know he was told to
keep out atlantic city
he should have listened
scarfa goes to long john
wants to set up mccullough you do the
murder
long john's going to willingly accept
that because this is how he's going
to prove himself with respect to
becoming a mob member
people don't realize it takes a lot of
balls to walk up and put a gun up to
someone's head
i meant long john he said you got balls
like an elephant
basically we got a piece of work to do
i want you to do it do a murder
with the guy that's right next to the
boss
it's an honor to be asked i said all
right no problem
[Music]
got a box of flowers so i could lay the
peace and the silence or in there
trying to be like a dumb delivery guy
we arranged me about five o'clock that
night
long john i think he had his gold
lincoln that day
i got in the back knotted each other
we proceeded over the benjamin franklin
bridge
heading towards northeast philadelphia
[Music]
long john pointed out the house
he turned around and sat a couple houses
down in his car
i got out with the flowers
i went up knocked on the door
and as soon as john answered the door he
looked at me just like you're looking at
me and i just put the silencer up to his
forehead
it was over and that was that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
long johnson man i love you i love you
handed me five thousand dollars in cash
and said listen buy yourself some suits
sixty-year-old mccullough was gunned
down nine days before christmas in his
northeast philadelphia home
delivery man kills him in front of his
wife
people were just absolutely stunned by
that you wonder
what is the darkness of the individual
who's a member of the mob
long john got made and became initiative
member because of that hit
he was worthy of being part of the
organization
he became scarfo's number one man on the
[Music]
street
long john definitely wanted to control
the whole
business of meth in every aspect
someone won't cooperate kill him
we'll just take over his whole operation
[Music]
you